hello guys I'm Ryan the right here and
I'm Jerry the Jerry Wow
noise beyond noise while we're filming
thanks Andrea we hit 300k subscribers
like an hour ago
so we're here today to keep the train
going Batman V Superman official trailer
number dos just dropped every comment is
about how I haven't watched this yet and
why I'm an [ __ ] for not doing that
we've been waiting a few hours just
sitting around here waiting for this
trailer to drop yes then you must be new
that is first week
this away Clark Kent Daily Planet what's
your position on the bathroom honey in
Gotham he's Batman
civil liberties are being trampled on
their city people living in fear
thinking about the law the daily plan
criticizing neurosis think they're above
the laws a hypocrite for what you say
considering every time you're heroes
there's a cat on a tree you read
puff-piece editorial
about an alien had to burn the whole
place down most of the world doesn't
share your opinion his point maybe
Gotham City and me have a bad history
with freaks dressed like clowns
boys hmm Bruce Wayne that meets Clark
Kent I love it I love bringing people
together how are we what hi hello Lex it
is a pleasure out what does a good grip
you should not pick a fight with this
person
the oldest lie in America senator the
power can be innocent
you're gonna go to war
as some [ __ ] brought the war to us
you know you can't win this it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world Son of Krypton
versus path of God you're psychotic
just a three syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds
tiny guard what it means to be a man you
be dead already
they just revealed it if I don't kill
God
if you don't we'll do it
what have you done
ah
that's to say whoa [ __ ] he would you
hello cheers with you um I mean on the
one hand it's a pretty sick trailer on
the other hand I feel like we just saw
the movie I feel like the last minute of
that trailer like the last like 30
seconds they just gave away like some
big surprises and it kind of seemed like
a parody of itself uh yeah when he was
like is he issue with you like I don't
know what voice then athletes doing in
this one I'm watching this trailer and
honestly you know I'm psyched for this
film still AM yeah yeah but I have my
concerns this videos gonna get so many
dislikes because I'm I really like
everyone else right I really like the
first two-thirds of this trailer cuz
it's all the fun yeah you want to see
and then the last third I'm like oh good
there's all that senseless destruction I
didn't like about the first movie and
you know here is a what seems like kind
of like a foregone conclusion but a bit
of a spoiler for the tree I've gotta
argue with you though
that that all craziness of the fighting
is with Batman and Superman and I'm
excited for that to watch Batman is
Superman wife or gonna die who cares
Batman and Superman need to have their
fight they do but like this all around
on but as the that's the problem with
Man of Steel is Superman's supposed to
protect all these people and he just
[ __ ] hit like so many people died in
Metropolis but it's gonna happen I know
and that's what Batman so pissed off
about they're acknowledged for certain
comment like I'm sure that there's other
circumstances or maybe is that doomsday
I I think so maybe doomsday is the one
destroying those David still it's just
like I feel like it adds insult to
injury to have one of these movies with
so much carnage because it works against
the superhero mythos in and of itself
you know
ah I'm frustrated this trailer gotta
admit frustrated um just gonna be really
honest with you guys like when it starts
off I was like really cool this isn't
about Batman vs Superman right now we're
seeing Bruce Wayne vs. Clark Kent other
ideals there are there other political
point of views and stuff like that like
that's where they're already like
butting heads you know I like that
they're both distrustful of each other
and issuing the fact that they both
pretty much do the same job yeah where
do you get off Bruce and like it's cool
that's your [ __ ] job man
it's cool that Lex brought them together
too that is the one I guess in the
minority but I'm Jesse Eisenberg as the
thing I'm most excited for in this movie
it looks like he's having fun he looks
like he's having a blast and I am having
I got a mint now that we've seen footage
where they let the clips kind of go on a
little bit longer with his with his
scenes this performance makes a lot more
sense to me than when I saw Pryor in
another trailer you know I'm not seeing
Bruce Wayne like when I see Ben Affleck
I still see Ben Affleck not that that's
bad not saying Ben Affleck is gonna do a
bad job but when I watch it I'm not like
wow he's really embodied Bruce Wayne
like I feel like we're it's still Ben
Affleck now that I didn't have like you
know a couple nitpicks for just the
scenes they showed but I actually was
kind of surprising I had the opposite
reaction cuz I've not been like losing
my mind as much for this move but I was
like oh yeah he's he's an alright Bruce
Wayne I'm kind of down with this it's
only a few clips but I was I was alright
I was sort of pleasantly surprised by
his Bruce Wayne because I didn't know
what to expect and I felt like
especially now at this point it's career
I'd be distracted by it it's Ben Affleck
I'm kind of looking for more charisma
type Henry Cavill now very cabals kind
of a because serious dude isn't he well
kind of a face like performance and this
again this might just be a neck pick but
like in that first scene the trailer is
like they gave him the most cartoony
glasses and now it's calling attention
for me anyway how sexy he is yeah and
they're working like they're not even
making him look like a dweeb now like so
I don't know how to feel I really wish
they didn't put wonder what like I wish
they would have left that is a project
we already know she's there I wish we
could have just discovered that moment
on
on our own with Zack Snyder coming on
board again I was like okay you did Man
of Steel which have like no humor to it
and then really and then I'm watching
his trailer and I'm like it looks like
he kind of learned his lesson is
infusing some humor he's not going crazy
handheld or some handheld in there but
it's not like it doesn't look as much
like some of his other sort of mid
period movies were like everything is a
slow-motion painting that looks like you
should hang it on your wall like this
looks like it's a little more concerned
with just being a movie dude this
trailer just ruin the tension between
Batman and Superman yeah I really wish
they didn't you know them getting along
at the end yeah why would you because I
feel like we saw the movie in a nutshell
yeah okay Batman is Superman oh they're
gonna fight each other
Lex is gonna create doomsday atoms oh I
don't know people are gonna feel loved
that like that's Act one two and three
it's like oh we have to one is Bruce
Wayne versus Clark Kent Act two is
Superman versus Batman Act three it's
all we got a team up for bigger evil
exactly and I that's such a cliche with
these verses films I know someone's
gonna jump in the comments if you Leroy
can't you just enjoy but I'm like you
know we've got so many of these movies
now that if you can't keep them fresh
and if you cannot you know make them
Siddalee special every time in some way
you know that's a problem yeah because
it's very generic to do it that way like
have them verse each other but then some
bigger threat comes in and now they're
teaming up to and it's like thing it's
all you want that was gonna happen and I
just wish we could have seen it unfold
for the movie and not not have to be so
aware of it in this trailer like the way
to build this movie is to hype Batman vs
Superman
don't show them working together because
then that gives us a reason to find out
what that means we're gonna be waiting
around and the whole tension between
them fighting we know is gonna be okay
because yeah they're gonna resolve it in
the end because they got to work
together with Wonder Woman who's cameo
they just gave away their introduction
at least it looks like her introduction
I can't believe they gave away her
introduction I'm all for having Wonder
Woman right I'm a little weary that they
like crammed her into this movie because
they're trying to catch up to Marvel but
that would have been a real nice
surprise I would have loved to have
cheered at that moment in the train in
the theater and maybe it'll be different
but
you know it's a bummer to know that now
yeah okay we're to see it we already
knew what sucks is that the marketing
for this movie I felt really just let it
down it's like come on take a page out
of JJ Abrams book for one second and
realize reviewing the whole movies not
cool secondly we have like everyone's
gonna see this movie anyway yeah and
secondly what they revealed did not
really like it yeah that's the other
part to it is like I like like from a
marketing standpoint it's like you're
just the title of your movie and the
idea that you have a like you know you
got Ben Affleck and famine and Lex
Luthor and Superman like people forgot
how they felt about Man of Steel and got
immediately yeah this movie you don't
need to convince us that hard anymore
yeah but then the information they
exposed I was like not really caring for
that but and it's also missing like the
stuff that was interesting about the
original trailer with all like false god
and the people the theme like yeah the
what the rest of the city is doing you
know cuz that's important you know
especially now that superhero cinema is
so huge and the superhero story is
problematic in terms of actual society
yeah I hope that's still in this movie
and yeah that's like cool I hope it's
not just like couldn't like confuse
totally on what it wants to be I mean
the things I liked about it it shot well
I'm always gonna be shot in the effects
look cool the costumes look cool jesse
eisenberg i know it's like really split
amongst how people feel about him so far
I'm getting more on board with him and
that is all so for me it's just like I'm
so happy at least somebody is gonna be
fun in this movie yeah cuz cuz you're
severe cinema now is so so dour and so
serious and gritty and important and
like mmhmm it's nice to at least have
some fun wallpaper and Ben Affleck as
Bruce Wayne like even though I'm still
where's Ben Affleck II I like Ben
Affleck you look state I still I'm like
most of his performances of the last few
movies he's done you know like I sighed
the first two-thirds of this film was
wicked fun really cool action-packed
thrilling I was like I would enjoy
watching this trailer just made me go
then one thing to really look
or to is the fight with Batman and
Superman but I'm kind of worried about
other things yeah like the first
trailers like oh I'm actually interested
these are some cool ideas and now this
trailer I'm a little bit like oh alright
well guys sorry to disagree with you and
how you felt
um there's definitely cool [ __ ] in there
like it looks cool but but yeah yeah I
mean though it looks cool but there's no
doubts that got infused in me and
worries and anger towards the marketing
team anyway guys listen hey if you're
new to the channel and if you still like
us yeah you can subscribe you the real
rejects by clicking this button in
between our heads heads heads two heads
are better than one stubble da doe
either pleasure you can check out
reasons to Jerry and dank ass Stubbs on
this channel to ultimate playlists on
the real rejects follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope
because if we get more followers we can
get product placement cuz money is
really what makes this world go round
and round sadly yeah I want everyone to
hear me when I say this I mean so
truthful money equals happy no don't
teach people of squares let's turn you
know that's not true
I know for it's a fact babe Bing Monica
are you gonna yell at me in front of
everyone right now front of all 300
let's just be real alright money pays
for this apartment in the new couch that
I just got that you guys see in the
video
it's probably
do I look high yeah it's gonna be all
the comments on this video
Ryan you look so stoned that's because
um I want her to fly as high as Superman
before I watch this women to a very high
altitude and got very lightheaded very
quick app which hey cheers to 300,000
whoo this videos never gonna